Bộ quên tệ thương mại và công nghiệp nhạc bản cho biết giá sang bán lệ trương bình đã tăng lên một trong chính người
phải tâm yên mỗi lý, mức cao nhất kể từ khi nước này bắt đầu thông cây và năm ninh chính trong chính người,
mức giá này được những giản sau khi chính phủ trên khai biển pháp bởi khó dự trữ dấu của sai,
nhằm ord định kể trường. Theo báo cáo giá sang lệ tăng thêm hai nhi chính nghiên trị trong khai ngày, kể từ khi
một dấu dự trữ được đưa ra thị trường. Dễ biến này cho thấy ám lật tăng giá như liệu vẫn lơn,
trong bối cảnh hình trường nước lượng tăng cầu đây biến đậu, chính của người bạn đã quy định giải phòng tám
mươi trự thung dầu từ khó dự trữ. Đồng thời dự kiến nối lại chính xét trở giá,
với mức hỗ trợ hương bán mèi một lý sang từ ngày mi trình thông mà,
tuy nhiên các bạn pháp này cần thời gian để phát truyệu qua. Chúng khi đó,
giờ phân tích nhận định giá như liệu tăng cao có thể tôi sẽ cách lên chỉ vì sản xuất và tiêu dùng,
anh gần tới trên vào phục hối kinh tế của người bạn trong thời gian tới.